i can hear the heads exploding already a
majority of republicans say they want
president trump to run again in 2024.
that's according to a new poll that
finds 54 percent of gop voters
want to see trump stage the political
comeback of a lifetime
but in the meantime the president giving
his blessing to the biden transition
process
while still vowing to keep up his legal
fight quote
remember the gsa has been terrific and
emily murphy has done a great job
but the gsa does not determine who the
next president of the united states will
be
here's more from the president today the
dow jones industrial average
just broke for the first time in history
30 000.
it's now uh that's good it's great for
jobs and it's good for
everything with the vaccines now coming
out one after another it's an incredible
thing that happened
one of the greatest medical achievements
that this
planet has ever seen so you're pretty
confident he runs again
absolutely absolutely by the way
uh an overwhelming percentage of
republicans do not buy this election
when you ask them they think it's
fraudulent but 30 percent
of republicans feel the same way but
democrats democrats feel the same way
about it they think that joe biden stole
the election and they're okay with it
they're right it makes me sick anyway
but to this point 2024
this is the sequel right and for a
sequel you need a break that's long
enough
to make you miss the first four years
right so you get the first excite you
have the excitement of the first movie
trump 2020 and then you yearn for part
two
but you need that part in between where
joe biden poops the bed
you know he brings he might even bring a
new war in high taxes
he might allow crime and unemployment to
soar so trump will end up cruising back
into the white house
fairly easily this is why i i mean i
think that i know that trump supporters
are upset about the outcome of
the election and the media's hand in
this but this might end up being better
than you
might expect for one reason if trump
had remained in 2020 the odds are there
would have been a massive scandal
to to hobble him because that's what
happens you if you
the second term you had watergate you
had monica lewinsky
you had iran contra you had others i
space on so how do you beat a second
term two first terms
he had a lot of scandals in the first
team with a but with a really boring ass
intermission in between so people look
guys back
awesome even the press jeff zucker will
be going thank god he's
back dana the press does love a rematch
and i think maybe
if they do cover biden for four years or
cover up for him
that you know they're gonna be itching
to get trunk back in the ring and you
know a big collision all over again i
think a lot of
reporters longed to be bored like they
were like they didn't want to wake up on
sunday morning and go oh my gosh here we
go again
they've never had a break but i think
that you know boredom when that sets in
after a while you're like then you
want something else and i think that
president trump he will have
a big platform he will have a lot of
influence
the first influence you'll see as i
imagine him
weighing in on the georgia senate races
yeah that would be kind of the first
test but what
what this also does however is there are
a lot of 2024
republican hopefuls and now they are all
playing freeze tag
in georgia because they don't want to
make a move if they think they're going
to make him met
so that will stifle a lot of republicans
for a while you're right about that um
what do you think
the argument would be so let's just say
the economy kind of wobbles around for
the next four years you know trump can
come back and say listen
i can get this thing back humming again
like i did and hey i was the one that
delivered the vaccines
that's a pretty strong argument if that
plays out absolutely
it makes complete sense to me that you
would see over 50 percent
think that trump would be the front
runner and then i think the second
runner up to that would be mike pence
and
that makes sense that's who people have
had and we can't forget the fact i mean
joe biden so far has won by 6.5 million
more votes but trump got 10
million more votes than he did the time
before so there are plenty of people in
the country who
thought that the last four years were
hunky-dory or they didn't want to change
from it
and i don't know if the next four years
of normalcy a third obama term
is going to change their mind about that
but watching republicans
deal with the trump legacy like dana
said is going to be the most fascinating
part of it trump has already tweeted
about kelly loffler and left david
perdue off of one tweet
there are people who are saying they
should write in trump in the georgia
sent off uh senate runoffs
which is obviously incredibly dangerous
for those candidates on the ballot
and he will play king maker for the next
four years because people will continue
to run in his legacy because it has
worked down ballot it just didn't work
at the top of the ticket
and if if biden governs like a lot of
people think he might
he can invite a challenge maybe a
primary challenge that can weaken him
and then really have president trump
come in and attack somebody fantasy
it's my fantasy and let me pass yourself
here for it let me tell you
insult his fantasy bernie already said
he'll think about it if biden doesn't go
oh my gosh and bur i wouldn't put it
past bernie wow
but what could weaken the biden
administration over four years is just
constant criticism
from the the bat you know getting
shipped in the back by people on the far
left
like that gaggle of young gals who are
currently in
congress uh the press is going to try
and act like trump is irrelevant and by
trying to act that way they're going to
continue to make him relevant
i thought the telltale sign today and by
the way greg you did call this
thank you you you called it you know
exactly how to butter him up
yes everybody was talking about it
i was first he just likes to claim
credit i got ridiculous even trump was
talking about it remember third term
exactly so i i don't know me today when
he walked in the white house
in the briefing room and he walked in
front of the mic and went down 30 000
vaccines and then walked out he didn't
quite do that
but uh what but the biggest problem for
the democrats will be
so the about 74 million people who voted
for trump
in the last four years they were bigoted
nazi racist
it's gonna get worse those 74 million
people
you know eat bowls of kittens for
breakfast and have gmaw and grandpa
locked up in the cellar that's the level
of loathing that you're gonna hear from
the left
about trump voters so bring it on
because it gives rise to trump bring it
on